l'histoire veut que lorsqu'un grec
débarque dans une cité il réserve sa
première visite au pop de la paroisse
sans église pas de communauté dit
certains ça tombe bien à marseille
l'église orthodoxe est toujours debout
ce matin elles ont beau même d'un parfum
de basilic la plante est au centre de la
cérémonie du jour la résurrection de la
croix pour les grecs orthodoxes c'est le
début d'une nouvelle année de prière à
marseille la piété reste le ferment de
la communauté hellénique joan as mussig
ou dit le sait bien ici tout le monde la
connaît installé depuis dix ans à
marseille elle et l'instit la prof
johanna est une enseignante grec
missionné par l'état grec pour apprendre
le grec moderne aux petits grec de
marseille
à la sortie de la messe et l'église
tient lieu d'agora monsieur le consul de
grèce consult difficile alors de ne pas
aborder la crise économique qui ébranle
le pays pour nos deux fonctionnaires
expatriés c'est bien plus qu'un mythe on
a pris des décisions très difficiles on
a pris des mesures qui sont pas qu'ils
sont pas qu'ils sont pas aimables
tous les deux fait un effort salarial
oui une baisse une baisse de 20% nous
les deux nous avons eu deux
une baisse de 20 % parce que nous sommes
tranquilles mais moi je les accepte si
c'est le prix de nous sortir de la crise
si ravi de le payer
pour le citoyen grec les lois de
l'économie sont impénétrables
et dieu dans tout ça face au déficit de
l'état le premier des paroissiens
marseillais à une solution moins
douloureuse surtout résoudre aussi par
un appel à des aides supérieure après le
début de l'année liturgique place à
celui de l'année scolaire johanna seront
à l'école où elle dispense chaque
mercredi des cours de grec du cp à la
terminale le plaisir est immense parce
que déjà on peu à côté de la langue ça
passe aussi de la civilisation la
culture crainte est donc à travers la
langue on l'est on les approche un
autant à leurs racines
c'est pas facile à rouler non
la première que je voulais à marseille
j'avais l'impression que j'étais
atteignent
certains ayant porté
les cours se déroulent dans les locaux
d'une des deux associations
communautaires de la ville la plupart
des élèves sont issus de la troisième
voire quatrième génération d'immigrés
[Musique]
voilà le président élu
dans le bureau du directeur en cette
rentrée l'ambiance est plutôt morose la
crise au pays frappent de plein fouet
l'activité de l'association la seule
aide que nous avions et depuis des
années de la part de l'état gré et c'est
une aide très très importante et je le
dis et le redis à chaque à chaque
réunion où chaque fois qu'il ya du monde
c'est de détacher ses enseignants pour
l'éducation
et c'est vrai que ça a même pris ça une
goutte et que et que là bas il a fallu
prendre des décisions résultat l'état
rapatrie ses enseignants l'an dernier
six professeurs assurer les cours de
langues désormais avec johanna ils ne
sont plus que 3 vous avez peur pour
votre poste mais sur bien sûr c'est vers
ça va on d'ores et déjà que l'an
prochain ils n'ont plus que deux au lieu
de ça on sait pourquoi ils sont pas vite
monsieur je l'annonçais pas savoir pour
l'heure pas question de se laisser
abattre la classe continue
ma collègue responsable du collège
aujourd'hui c'est andromaque la collègue
de johanna qui dispense les cours
ce cours est essentiel pour les grecs de
marseille la transmission de la langue
c'est l'élément clé de leur identité
de classe au collège 10 comme les grecs
et en grèce ils disent qu'on est
français on est un peu des deux en grèce
on se sent plus craquer en france les
français
mais chez nous partout mais
et ils ont de quoi se sentir chez eux
nos petits hélène leur histoire et même
gravé dans le marbre du vieux-port leurs
ancêtres les phocéens en ont fait l'un
des plus grands comptoirs de la
méditerranée il y à 2600 ans plus proche
de nous la guerre avec les turcs en 1920
puis la misère en 1960 ont poussé des
milliers de grecs a trouvé refuge dans
la cité phocéenne aujourd'hui il serait
à peine plus de deux mille à y résider
suffisamment pour que résonne dans les
rues de la ville un petit air de
bouzouki
bienvenue au cours de danses
traditionnelles de yanis un jeu de
jambes à faire pâlir les meilleurs
boxeurs et pourtant la moyenne d'âge ne
descend pas en dessous de 40 ans la
plupart sont d'origine grecque et
viennent sur le tas retrouver leurs
racines
ici entre deux danses la crise s'invite
dans la conversation et pour nos
baladins les traditions sont les
meilleures armes contre la morosité les
grecs ils doivent aussi au temps de
danser et chanter qu'à voir la crise ils
sont toujours besoin d'exprimer ce
qu'ils ressentent que ce soit dans le
plaisir ou ou là où dans la peine il
faut que ça passe par la musique la
danse
les liens les fêtes excusez moi j'étais
quand même c'est sept jours ce côté
optimiste que les gars qu ils ont pris
le virus de jambes à la grecque qui même
dans l'art dans la dans les problèmes il
était toujours joyeux gay je conduirai
un jour un zorba danser résorbant mange
est aussi un peu si le de quitter les
grecs de marseille sans faire un tour
dans les cuisines de jean marie dit le
grec figure locale et gardien des
saveurs crétoise avec sa célèbre pitt a
flambé à l'ouzo le pastis des grecs
son appel le polisseur de
l'établissement et ailleurs qui a deux
poids deux mesures donc ça soit tu le
manges et j'aime ça soit tiennent pas
j'te pousse jeu le marge et tu le payes
voilà c'est propre net et sans bavure
dans son restaurant très peu de grecs
mais des français gastronomes les
régaler pour jean marie c'est sa
contribution au pays nous ici on
essayait de faire en sorte que les gens
aient envie d'aller voir ce qui se passe
là bas parce que ça leur plaît ce qui se
passe ici donc on sait que ce qui y
verront là bas ça leur père un poil
marron
après ça on travaille pour le tourisme
de demain
depuis qu'ulysse a mis les voiles grecs
des marseillais ont traversé toutes les
crises sur le vieux-port pastis et ou
zoho feront toujours bon ménage
[Musique]